Hey there!
Are you ready to understand a song in English?
Let's learn English with Taylor Swift's hit new song, "Me!".
So, if you want to understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles,
then be sure to hit that Subscribe button and the bell down below
because we help you to do that every single week.
Hey! Do you want to understand fast-speaking natives?
Well, we want to help you out!
We teach you exactly how in our
FREE 3-part mini-course.
You can learn more about that and sign up by clicking up here,
or down in the description below.
Do you love Taylor Swift?
We've actually done a couple lessons with her music and an interview.
You can find all of those in this new playlist by clicking up here,
or down in the description below.
Alright, I hope you've had a lot of fun learning with the song.
Remember, if you want to maximize your fluency, to listen to it again and again
to really remember all of that new vocabulary and improve your pronunciation by singing along!
Now, if you want to support our channel,
and let YouTube know that you want
more videos like this,
then be sure to hit that Like button below,
and remember to also Subscribe!
Also, check out that FREE 3-part mini-course
that I told you about.
Check out this playlist with all of our lessons
teaching you English with songs!
And, this other lesson I think you'll really enjoy!
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww yeah!